process of this we did discover that a
foreign national
Christopher Steele was paid through
fusion GPS used Russian sources that not
only weren't verified turn with debunked
are you concerned that that was paid for
to manipulate the American people in the
lead-up to an election isn't that closer
to the mandate than Michael Cohen why
isn't that having some players Muller on
that sir have it having having something
to do with paying some stormy Daniels
woman 130,000 I mean which is gonna turn
out to be perfectly legal that money was
not campaign money sorry I'm giving you
a fact now that you don't know it's not
campaign money no campaign finance
violation so they funneled it through
the law firm funnel throw offer him and
the president repaid it oh I didn't know
that he did yeah there's no campaign
finance law zero so the president like
every Shan so what this decision was
made by everybody everybody was nervous
about this from the very beginning I
wasn't I knew how much money Donald
Trump put into that campaign I said 130
thousand ain't gonna do a couple of
checks four hundred and thirty dollars
when I heard Cohen's retainer of 35,000
when he was doing no work for the
president mmm I said well that's how it
was repaying that's how he's repaying it
with a little profit and a little margin
for paying taxes for Michael Flores de
but you know the president didn't know
about this I believe that he did I know
about the specifics of it as far as I
know but he did know about the general
arrangement that Michael would take care
of things like this like I take care of
things like this for my clients I don't
burden them with every single thing that
comes along these are busy people